[Music]
it was june 23 2019 and i was visiting
the zetree refugee camp in jordan
and the zitri camp is an interesting
sight to see because across the horizon
there in the middle eastern desert where
ancient civilizations once lived is a
makeshift settlement of row after row
after row of corrugated metal trailer
and this is where the folks in zachary
live
often they have paintings on the side
drawn by children in the camp
and on that day i was visiting with a
colleague of mine who works for save the
children jordan and we got to meet a
friend of mine named esma
we visited esma's trailer and we knocked
on the wooden door and esthema kindly
greeted us as she always does with such
great kindness and we walk in and we sit
on the dark brown carpet on a dark brown
cushion with the blue flowers all around
the trailer
and we sit and we drink tea together shy
in arabic the shy that she had prepared
for us
and as we were drinking our tea esma was
talking to us about her life in the camp
her life back in syria and the great
work she's doing in the camp suddenly
there was a loud noise around us and so
the trailer wall started rumbling it
felt like the ground was shaking
and finally i looked over to my
colleagues as i looked over to esma said
something going on and esma said yes
just wait
and in that moment 10 children burst
through that wooden door we had come
through onto the ground and the carpet
and the brown carpet in front of us
and rolled around and and played with
one another and the the room had become
chaos
and just a few seconds later
they each stand up give esma a big hug
and greet her esma says hello to each of
them by name
a greeting in arabic
she says it to each of them and then
finally they sit down in a semi-circle
around esma and esma sits with them
and she grabs a hold of a children's
book that was there
and suddenly after grabbing her baby boy
muhammad who had been crawling all over
the carpet putting her putting him
firmly in her lap
she begins the story and it's as if like
that a magical ambiance had taken over
the trailer
all the kids are so focused in they're
locked in they're listening to
everything esma has to say as she reads
the pages of the book and the dialogue
she reads with her voice moving up and
down like that of an actress to make
sure the kids are engaged
and this book in particular is one about
a syrian boy who
in his words wants to be a pilot of love
not a pilot of war
so this goes on for some time esmera
reads a page of the book and then uh she
pivots the book so that she can show it
to everybody uh all the kids the
illustrations in the book and the kids
lean in and they're they're eager their
eyes wide to see what was on the page
that esma had just described
and finally after about five ten minutes
of reading
asthma closes the book suddenly
it says el nihaya which means the end in
arabic
the magical ambiance is gone and and the
kids are going back to their raucous
behaviors they're playing with one
another they're hanging out but and they
they head out the door eventually but
not before they give esthema one more
big hug
one more greeting to let them know to
let her know how much they love her
esma is a poet author entrepreneur and
storyteller in the zutri refugee camp in
jordan
but it took a lot for her to get there
esma grew up in the town of
syria
where she
lived her life of relative peace
and stability with her with her family
that ended in 2012 when the syrian war
began and when her house was burned to
the ground along with all of her
belongings including the journals that
she had written her whole life's
memories and stories about
and then she crossed the desert to go to
the zetra camp in jordan and within two
years of her time in the camp
came the darkest moment of her life
which is the miscarriage of her child
due largely to a lack of readily
accessible health care
he was in the middle of this darkness
the darkest moment of her life that espa
found the spark within her
the spark being this children's
storytelling initiative that i described
esma wanted to make sure that not a
single child in the zachary camp not one
child
felt as though they did not have a
future that these children who had dealt
with words like war violence bombings
shellings for too long
and who had grown up knowing very little
other than the zachary camp
would have hope for a future would have
the ability to dream
and would feel confident and and
empowered in who they are and that's why
esma started this storytelling
initiative that now brings dozens and
dozens of children to her trailer each
month each week
esma is one of the most inspiring people
i have ever met in my life
but when we hear the stories of refugees
in the media and from the mouths of many
politicians
we don't hear esma's story
we tend to hear the stories of victims
or of villains two binary stories
either we hear the story of victims
people who
are looked down upon should be looked
down upon
why because they don't have agency
because they're pitiful human beings who
need to be given a handout
or we're told the story of villains
why do we look down upon refugees
because they're criminals they're going
to take our jobs and they're going to
ruin our our country's cultures if
they're welcomed in
either way we're told to look down at
refugees
in reality refugees could not be further
from these tropes that are that i just
described and these refugees are
powerful
creative inspiring people some of the
most resilient
innovative human beings on the planet
refugees contribute economically
the us government found that in the 10
years ending in 2014 the net fiscal
impact of refugees on the american
economy was about 63 billion dollars
that's above and beyond the investment
it takes
the small investment but mighty
investment it takes to bring refugees
into the country
a small investment that would pay
dividends but one that has not done
enough especially as resettlement
centers have been decimated over the
last few years
refugees are some of the most
entrepreneurial people on earth and the
most extreme entrepreneurs they're 1.5
to 2x more entrepreneurial than native
born citizens in the us
and they create jobs millions of jobs
for for people around the world in their
new adopted countries and in camps like
zetri
beyond economics socially refugees
are there for our most difficult times
so when hurricane harvey hit houston it
was the afghan cultural center and many
others of course that was providing aid
to firemen firefighters firemen and
women who were helping ensure that
people were protected and safe and
provided with food and water and what
they needed
in utica when utica new york
when there were factory closures across
the rust belt and when a town that was
once fast growing was dwindling in
population as people abandoned it
it was refugees from 40 countries that
rekindled the spirit there
that repopulated churches and mosques
that brought hope to a city that was
declining rapidly and is now stabilized
and most recently during this pandemic
refugees have provided food for the
elderly changing their small businesses
and and
into opportunities to serve uh folks who
are most disadvantaged during the
pandemic providing food and and
equipment that's necessary
but more importantly than what refugees
contribute is who refugees are
equal human beings with dignity that
deserve to be treated with respect just
like all of us
as one poet says no one chooses refugee
camps
they didn't choose their situations and
it could have happened to any of us
they're equal human beings who deserve
respect independent of their
contributions
and i believe we all deep down know this
we know that refugees and all other
people different than us are equal human
beings who deserve respect
but there's a disconnect
because when polled the majority of
americans have said in the past that
they do not want to welcome
syrian refugees to this country at all
or they only want to welcome syrians
from certain religions and backgrounds
and in some ways this disconnect
actually
is intuitive it's very sad but it's
intuitive because in the absence of
knowing a syrian or knowing a refugee or
knowing someone in any group that is
different than us we have to fill in the
gaps
and where do we fill in the gaps we fill
in the gaps from the cacophony of sounds
and media clips and politicians speeches
and headlines and politicized things
that are all over the media that tell us
the victim or the villain narrative
not the narrative that says
these are beautiful human beings
with with lives of dignity that are
being played out in communities we don't
hear the story of esma we don't hear the
story of utica we don't hear the story
of houston after harvey
my hope is for three things
most urgently my hope is that the world
takes its duty that it committed to
after world war ii and welcomes refugees
into their countries there are 27
million refugees in the world right now
a number that has gone up over the last
week as half a million ukrainians
have huddled together in train stations
to exile out of their country
because of the horrendous violence
that's occurring in ukraine
my hope is that
countries band together and commit to
welcoming refugees because right now we
are failing miserably
only a shocking 0.2 percent of refugees
in the world are resettled because
nations are failing to accommodate and
to welcome them
beyond that my hope is that there are
more stories that allow us to look past
the victim or villain narratives more
authentic human stories that bring the
voices of people like esma into our
lives
my book that's coming out in may 25
million sparks is meant to tell the
untold story of refugee entrepreneurs
including esma and i hope it contributes
to that
but beyond the stories
i have a greater hope
and that hope is that each of us when
we're faced with these stories and
narratives
about who refugees are or who people of
different races or ethnicities or
religions than us are
we stop and we look within
and we remember
that yes everyone is equal to us and
that their differences should be honored
and respected and that everyone deserves
to be treated with dignity just the way
esma treats those wonderful children
in her trailer during her storytelling
initiatives in the camp
and that everyone everyone is a powerful
beautiful creative human being who
deserves to be treated with equal
respect and love
thank you
[Music]